OK, so yesterday we have Michigan pro
Trump protesters gathering to demand
that votes not be counted. In Arizona,
armed pro Trump protesters gathered
to demand that votes be counted and to attack
Fox News. This is just unbelievable. Here's
video from Simon Romero. He's a correspondent
for The New York Times. You will see if you're
watching. You won't hear this, but you'll
see that one guy is armed with a long gun.
You will hear chants of shame on Fox,
which I will explain in a moment on Fox.
So shame on Fox refers to Fox calling Arizona
for Joe Biden and Trump ists, I guess are furious
about that. The Associated Press also called
Arizona for Joe Biden. Here's another video. This
is still in Phenix where a chant of Fox, a chant
of Fox News sucks breakout. Take a look at this.
A lot of people in the crowd who are not wearing
masks where we're keeping a respectful distance,
but a loud and very boisterous crowd.
You'll start hearing them start up here
and they're actually chanting Fox
News. Fox News sucks. The reason
why they're chanting that is because Fox
News called Arizona for Biden yesterday.
And a lot of people are angry about that.
We have not called Arizona. All right.
So the protesters then moved from
the capital in Phenix, the site
of that last video to the Maricopa. County
recorder's building where they started chanting
Stop the steel, naturally, you will notice
almost not a single mask in sight this, but.
We need oversight to verify
that this person isn't alive.
Here's another video where you
can't really tell who's saying what
other than you do hear the term mail in
ballots at one point and the shark attack.
Let's check on the.
Not only Democrats,
these protests are not only pathetic on
principle, but the added layer is that there
are almost no masks. The United States had one
hundred and eight thousand new cases yesterday,
more than 1200 new deaths yesterday. And they're
not only protesting who the hell knows what,
there's also barely a mask in sight. As
Simon Romero also reported, as time went on,
the number of guns went up as well. As you can see
in this next picture, we're showing the open carry
handgun guy with a Trump hat. Then here is an
armed pro Trump protester in full gear, reportedly
named Rich, 30 years old, with an AR 15. He was
mad, according to Simon Romero, who interviewed
him, mad about Biden wanting to, quote, tax guns.
How ironic or tragic is it that the very monsters
out there protesting and angry at Fox News were
partially created by Fox News? I think that that's
something we should not should the the irony and
tragedy of that should not be lost on us. Now,
sadly, when people show up armed and wreak havoc.
It does have an effect. Maricopa County in Arizona
had to close down its ballot counting facility
to the media and to the public. Now it was
open to the people counting votes. The vote count
continued. But because of this heavily armed group
gathering outside the building, we have seen the
building have to be closed down to the public and
to the media. Fortunately, the votes will still
be counted. Now, by the way, is there any chance
that these guys, mostly guys, will be tear gassed
and told to disperse when nine p.m. comes like the
Black Lives Matter protesters all over the country
during the summer? No, not particularly likely. Do
these domestic terrorists want the votes counted
or not? I'm having trouble keeping track. But of
course, the reality is you have to understand
the Trumpy in view. If the counting might help
Trump, they want the votes to be counted. If the
counting might hurt Trump, they don't want the
votes to be counted. Don't you understand, guys?
Yashida says count votes that are good for us
don't count votes that are bad for us. And
that's as simple as it. It really is that simple.